يدي باخر التطورات في اسطنبول حيث اكد
والي المدينه تركيه عاليه يرلي قايا بسقوط
قتله وجرحى في الانفجار الذي هز منطقه
تقسيم وصل المدينه اليوم من دون ان تتضح
لحد الان اسبابه الانفجار وقع في شارع
الاستقلال الشهير السياحي بتقسيم وسمع
دويه قويه على همم بعد كبير من المنطقه
وعلى سلطات سنه على فرق الاسعاف والاطفاء
كما ارسلت خبراء في تفكيك المتفجرات
هذه الصور الاولى التي وصلتني الى غرفه
الاخبار حول هذا الانفجار الذي وقع في
التقسيم لحد الان لا نعرف سبب هذا
الانفجار مراسلنا في اسطنبول كان قد اكد
لنا ان السلطات التركيه
طلبت من وسائل الاعلام بدون بدون
تقديم معلومات عن انفجار حاله التاكد منها
ينضم الينا الان وحسين اسد من اسطنبول
اهلا بك حسين
ما هي المعلومات الجديده لديك
اربعه قتلى و 38 جريحا رفيق هي الحصيله
الاوليه التي اعلنها قبل دقائق من الان
ولي اسطنبول وهي حصيله مرجحه للارتفاع اذا
ما نظرنا الى هذه الصور التي التقطت عبره
كاميرات المراقبه وتظهر لحظه الانفجار
الذي تقول وسائل الاعلام انه اييي بسبب
حقيبه وضعت على احدى المقاعد في جده
الاستقلال من قبل سيده تركت المكان بعد
لحظاته وقع الانفجار وكان يعني عدد
الزوار في المكان كبيرا وكبيرا جدا
وبالتالي هذه الحصيله الاوليه مرجحه
للارتفاع والان يبدو ان الحديث قد بدا
يتداول عن ان الهجوم والانفجار هو هجوم
ارهابي الشرطه اغلقت المحيط المكان اغلقت
كل الطرق التي تؤدي الى شارع الاستقلال
طائرات همم الهليكوبتر التابعه للشرطه
تحوم في الاجواء سيارات الاسعاف لا تتوقف
دخولا وخروجا الى المنطقه فرق الادله
الجنائيه وصلت الى المكان بدعت بالعمل
بحثا عن خيوط اوليه لهذا الانفجار الذي
همم تتحدث الان وساري اعلام تركيا عن
احتماليه يكونا هجوما ارهابيا
حسين هذا الانفجار الاول منذ سنوات اخر
انفجار استهدف في مدينه اسطنبول كان في
عام 2017
دون شكل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
تحدث قبل يومين قال ان تركيا لم تعد من
البلدان التي يرتبط اسمها بالاحداث
والهجمات الارهابيه وبعد يومين من حديث
اردوغان هذا الانفجار في جده الاستقلال ان
تاكد انه هجوم ارهابي وبالتالي هذا الامر
يعيد الاذهان الى الاعوام الماضيه 2015
وما تلاها من سنوات شهدت فيها المدينه
وايضا مدن تركيه اخرى هجمات مسلحه في
اسطنبول وفي انقره وفي مدن قريبه من
الحدود السوريه لكن هذا المكان جده
الاستقلال قبله السياح عشرات الالاف من
همم السياح والسكان يزورون المكان بشكل
يومي من اكثر الاماكن همم ازدحاما في
اسطنبول الى ان لم يكن في كل تركيا هناك
انتشار امني واضح سواء من خلال رجال
الشرطه او حتى من خلال عناصر الامن بالزي
المدني الذين
جولون داخل همم ازقه والشوارع المؤديه الى
هذا المكان وبالتالي وقوع حد الانفجار
يؤشر الى وجود خلل امني ربما لذلك وضعت
السلطات التركيه همم خمسه من المدعيين
العامين لفتح تحقيق في ملابسات هذا الهجوم
ربما تتضح بعد همم ساعاتنا الان همم
الهجوم اسباب الهجوم دوافع الهجوم ربما
ايضا تبدا تركيا بالاشاره الى المتهمين في
في هذا الهجوم ان كان هجوم الارهابيا
بطبيعه الحال شكرا جزيلا لك حسين اسد
مراسلنا من اسطنبول شكرا الحسين